karfas always and only belonged to the
caffeine
we were never part of Valeria's Empire
nor have we ever fallen to it'th rocky
or our walls and the Red Waste outside
them guard us from such annoyance many
call the approach to our city the garden
of boners it needs a little tending to
grow our city however would be quite a
prize for any Empire Kath straddles two
worlds a greedy and curious West and a
rich and mysterious East the marvels of
ET and ash I passed through our markets
and share births with the riches of the
Free Cities and Westeros our ports have
fulfilled many a traders dreams almost
as many as they have broken we call
Qarth the greatest city that ever was or
will be an easy claim to make if one
knows only the docks and customs houses
of other cities an easy light to swallow
if a people see only the gold and jewels
of their rulers which we the 13 and
Governor City are careful to ensure the
proud caffeine shook off the yoke of
unjust Kings long ago so they are told
at festivals by the pure born the King's
direct descendants who have controlled
the thirteen ever since only now instead
of scepters they use ships a merchant
only remains on the thirteen until the
others are no longer afraid to deny him
or too afraid to deny his replacement
except for the warlocks they alone hold
a hereditary seat a relic from when they
had powers or at least from when the
world was younger and more easily duped
over the years we have developed an
understanding
they shall always be welcome on our
councils and at affairs of state
provided they never come rare is the
Civic problem that can be solved by
cryptic nonsense and shade of the
evening thankfully they need little
encouragement to confine themselves to
their house of the undying yet perhaps
we qartheen are too confined ourselves
we feel safe behind our walls and our
laws which no visitor can hope to follow
and by which any citizen who vouchers
for a guest always pays with his life
but like a ship in the summer seas a
city grows becalmed without fresh wind
the greatest city that ever was or will
be an epitaph I would prefer the
greatest city that is